desde que eu me conheço por gente eu
escuto tempo inteiro que eu sou
extremamente impaciente que eu sou
inconformada
eu me movimento tempo todo eu tive sorte
obviamente que não se na década de 80
porque naquela época e pela movimentação
foi a de criança não era considerado
hiperatividade não era muito menos
medicado
felizmente mas provavelmente eu tivesse
nascido nesta década eu estaria
completamente medicalizada sempre foi
também extremamente curiosa mas
engraçado porque toda vez que eu
escutava isso você curiosa você se
movimenta muito você muito impaciente
nunca ninguém me dizia isso de uma forma
positiva a sensação que eu tinha que
tudo isso era negativo era tudo negativo
e o que pensando mas como revelar né
porque pra que serve negativos não para
revelar é transformar em cores poder da
luz aquilo que de alguma forma a gente
não se conforma e eu fui pensando bom né
como vou revelar isso todo o primeiro
passo para a revelação um quarto escuro
um lugar não necessariamente iluminado
foi buscar em outros espaços para buscar
na guerra foi buscar nos desastres
fui buscar nos refúgios nos
deslocamentos forçados
resolvi sair por aí peguei meu diploma
resolvi andar por alguns países
fui buscando nesses quarenta países que
eu fui andando não necessariamente
escuridão mas como que eu podia e
revelando aquilo que de alguma forma
ainda estava escuro pra mim ainda era
inquietante mas que de alguma forma eu
sentia que podia assim se transformado
de uma outra forma
a primeira vez que eu me dei conta que
isso podia ser muito diferente
foi quando me encontrei com um grupo de
malucos como eu que acreditavam que
podiam fazer do seu diploma o podiam
fazer da sua história da sua trajetória
há um quê de verdade significa se muito
não só para si mesmo mas para outras
pessoas
isso me dá uma sensação boa não quer
dizer que pela actividade quer dizer que
pela movimentação que dizer que em
quietude impaciência
com não se conformar não necessariamente
era algo que prejudicavam nem a mim
provavelmente não ao mundo e eu comecei
encontrar de uma forma de outra foi
encontrando humano do mundo não
necessariamente só no outro mas em mim
fui olhando pra dor do outro para o
sofrimento porque ele era obrigado a se
deslocar àquele que era foi torturado
durante muito tempo escutamos histórias
que eram histórias que rasgavam na
rasgavam a audição rasgavam essa
sensação de de conforto que a gente vai
tendo quando a gente viu no mundo
aparentemente estável dentro de uma
estrutura que a gente nem sempre olha
por outro lado foi mesmo aquela sensação
de conforto que de alguma forma estava
tudo dado quando comecei a me dar conta
que eu cheirava mal que o ser humano
cheira mal e não estou falando disso uma
analogia tô falando cheiro de ser mesmo
né
estou falando o cheiro de quem não toma
banho eu me incluindo nem quando me dei
conta disso pela primeira vez o quanto a
gente máscara aquilo que de alguma forma
a gente acredita que é negativo
a gente vai se perder ele eu senti que
eu ia me perdendo senti que fui me
deixando foi deixando uma parte da minha
mãe e da minha humanidade mas
principalmente fui deixando de perceber
a humanidade do outro
quando comecei a me dar conta que talvez
eu precisava ficar um pouco mais
sensível não só à luz do outro mas a
minha própria luz que aquilo que até
então poderia ser escuro poderia ser
duro poderia ser sofrido poderia ser
aniquilador talvez fosse a melhor forma
de revelar aquilo que eu sentia dentro
de mim e que não era claro pra mim
literalmente não parecia ter cor não
parecia ter uma imagem e era difícil de
poder dizer que eu queria com isso né
porque eu queria ser psicóloga porque eu
queria ter gente em países que eu não
sabia nem existiu há pouco tempo atrás
eu não sabia nem que estão era um país
muito menos que era um país que tem um
conflito étnico
pouco tempo atrás eu me dei conta como
funcionava geografia da áfrica primeiro
fiquei com raiva de mim mesma como nunca
prestei atenção no estudo como eu nunca
parei para observar quem eram os meus
iguais porque de uma forma do outro a
gente está muito conectado em termos de
cultura de alimentação de cuidado com o
outro e fui percebendo que aquilo que
parecia escuro sombrio dolorido sem
sentido era o que de alguma forma e
iluminava a minha forma de perceber o
mundo e aí comecei a aprender a calma
minhas vísceras como é difícil a calma
as visitas quando a gente está no meio
de uma guerra a bomba está caindo e esse
talvez seja um grande diferencial de
alguém que trabalha numa rede de
urgência alguém que trabalha numa ajuda
humanitária em um contexto de guerra
quando a gente trabalha em uma rede de
urgência num país como o nosso a
urgência do outro a agência não é nossa
quando a gente trabalha na guerra quando
a gente trabalha na ajuda humanitária
uma situação de refúgio deslocamento
forçado de conflito armado
a dor e do outro mas a dor também é
nossa o risco que dele também nós o chão
que treme no terremoto para aquele que
estou cuidando também treme pra mim mas
isso não me faz mais ou menos psicólogo
cuidadora
mas me faz certamente muito mais próximo
da dor do outro
isso dá uma sensação boa de conforto que
bom que eu pude de alguma forma estudar
caminhar trilha e poder ocupar todos
esses passos dessa possibilidade de vir
e se acalmar as vísceras vem uma forma
de como poder perceber o mundo de
diferenças passos isso me dei conta
primeira vez quando eu perguntei pro
dodô era um psicólogo trabalhava na
minha equipe e um psicólogo congolês da
república democrática do congo
imagino que todo mundo sabe que existem
dois congos na república democrática do
congo e eu perguntei pra ele como eu
sempre pergunto quando chegam os países
eu pergunto o que aparentemente óbvio
pra todo mundo que mora num país né
como é que fala determinadas palavras o
que é uma pessoa bonita o que é uma
pessoa pra casar porque isso se escuta
em todos os países extremamente curioso
porque todo mundo responde
se tudo tivesse dado a primeira vez que
eu perguntei pro do ele disse à mulher
bonita mas como você não sabe ler bonita
uma mulher forte a mulher poderosa é uma
mulher que tem substância na minha
cabeça eu imaginei a mulher maravilha é
uma mulher forte uma mulher com uma
cintura fina uma mulher poderosa mulher
maravilha
ok fiquei satisfeita mas a imagem que
dodô me passava a imagem que ele que eu
projetava na minha própria cabeça com a
história que ele contava da mulher
maravilha
alguns dias depois a esposa de dodô que
estava vindo de uma outra cidade chegou
e ele disse vem cá que eu vou te
apresentar agora você vai conhecer de
verdade que é uma mulher que não é linda
mulher maravilhosa mulher mais linda do
mundo
e aí ele me apresentou a mulher dele a
mulher de dor sem brincadeira ela tinha
mais de 150 quilos e ele dizia olha isso
é uma mulher com substância uma mulher
forte é uma mulher corajosa é uma mulher
que enfrenta é uma mulher que marca
presença por onde ela passa a emi de
conteúdo tem toda a razão
numa questão de que de geografia e
história de referência não é minha
história não é minha geografia não é a
minha referência é aquele que contém
aquele que fala é daquele que faça
aquele que sente e eu fui me dando conta
que muitas vezes a gente fica incomodado
como eu quando criança né será que pra
que o programa sou eu que sou hiperativo
incomoda as pessoas como o movimento
incomoda as pessoas com as minhas
perguntas e de onde eu venho na minha
família eu escutava tem que ter uma
pergunta deira nada melhor que uma
psicóloga ser uma pergunta dela mas eu
sou entender isso anos mais tarde e
depois eu fui me dando conta que essa
curiosidade que poderia ser uma
fofoqueira de plantão também poderia ser
uma psicóloga de plantão para poder
ouvir outros espaços histórias de
pessoas que aparentemente não interessa
a todo mundo como aparentemente me
perguntava mas como você aprendeu a
ouvir os congoleses como você aprendeu
ouvir os quirguizes se você não fala a
língua deles mas eles também não fala
uma pessoa em choque quando está saindo
de um conflito armado está saindo de uma
guerra sendo deslocamento o que ela
menos utiliza é a fala o que ela mais
útil
isa é o couro então como aprender a lei
como aprender a ouvir como aprender a me
conectar com aquilo que eu não tinha
aprendido na universidade
é como se tivesse o tempo inteiro feito
exercícios durante cinco anos na
universidade eu fiz exercícios
resolvidos mas nunca ninguém me ensinou
exercitar as outras partes do corpo
quando me dei conta do poder que é você
chegar perto de alguém que você nunca
viu na vida que você não tem idéia que
liga essa pessoa fala que tipo de
sofrimento que tipo de tortura ela
sofreu e você se conecta com ela no
sentido que você senta junto a partir
daquele momento a guerra que era dela
agora também a sua a dor que era dela
agora também a sua um massacre que ela
sofreu agora também meu eu nunca volta
pra casa sem cicatrizes mas eu posso
olhar para aquilo como um ferimento
machucado ou posso encarar isso como
algo que de alguma forma me fortaleci me
deixa mais forte e esse é um pouco do
trabalho que eu venho fazendo nesses
últimos anos tentando ajudar conectado
com o outro lado do outro que eu nunca
vi na vida mostrar para ele a partir de
agora você não está mais sozinho a
partir do momento que você divide sua
história seja ela fala seja pelo corpo
seja por uma demanda muito prática que
você tá me dando a partir de agora sua
história também a minha e quando volto
pra casa eu nunca volte sozinho não
volto sem dor podem ter certeza
mas essa dor vai sendo ressignificado um
pouco a idéia está aqui que a minha dor
ou equador aquelas pessoas não sejam só
delas que sejam também anose partir do
momento que eu vejo a história de
sofrimento do outro com uma imagem de
televisão do mundo como eu vou perdendo
uma parte da minha imunidade
uma parte do meu desejo de estar no
mundo a partir do momento que eu olho
para o outro como alguém que o
sofrimento também é meu eu posso me
inquietar e esse talvez seja o meu
empreendimento me conectar com a dor do
outro mas principalmente fazer do outro
uma parte da minha razão de trabalhar da
minha razão de militar da minha razão de
tal andando por aí do mundo e esse eu
espero que seja um pouquinho da mensagem
que assim como eu
fazer revelar o meu desejo seja ele
preto branco ou colorido
o importante é ter a certeza que a
imagem que a gente tem na vida saiu do
negativo seja aqui seja lá seja em
qualquer outro lugar do mundo que a
nossa vida realmente saia do negativo